anderson cooper got quote really pissed
with his son's other dad ex benjamin
masani
i like order i like stability and i like
planning
yeah let's explain on wednesday anderson
made an appearance on the late show with
stephen colbert
and he shared a major mistake his ex
recently committed
i was away in israel last week was my
first work trip for 60 minutes and
i was doing an interview and i get this
text
from uh wyatt's other dad
benjamin and he said uh he just walked
exclamation mark exclamation mark
yeah you would think that would be my
reaction and instead of being excited
about his son's major milestone
anderson was not happy then i got really
pissed at benjamin
for i was like in my household when i
grew up you would lie about everything
so like he should have just lied and
he shouldn't have said he just walked he
should have lied and said oh no he's not
walking at all so when i got home and he
walked we would all be like oh my god
it's the first walk
although the cnn anchor missed his son's
first walk he has since seen his son do
the milestone multiple times
but he adds that his one-year-old hasn't
mastered it just yet and he walks like a
drunken sailor and uh not well then
he walks like someone at the rave in in
washington square park
uh which makes me a little worried about
what he was doing in israel don't give
him a knife
another milestone wyatt has conquered
talking
but according to anderson baby wyatt is
speaking his own language
he talks in a dialect of of hindi or
urdu i'm not sure but it's incredible
it's a really interesting dialect i'm
trying to understand
exactly what it is it doesn't make any
sense at this point but but he's very
committed to it
back in february the 53 year old news
anchor revealed during an appearance on
the ellen degeneres show
that he's not only co-parenting with his
ex-boyfriend benjamin
but they also still live together we
actually still live in the same
house because uh we get along really
well and
you know it's yeah it's weird but uh it
works out
yeah the cnn anchor opened up about
being a new dad to his wyatt
and how he's balancing daddy duties with
his ex who anderson
says initially wasn't so sure about
having a kid it was interesting because
he wasn't
really sure he wanted to have a kid
which was one of the reasons we probably
broke up
but then he came around the idea and now
he is
just such a great parent in fact he says
becoming a dad has turned benjamin into
a big softie
but all this time together doesn't
necessarily mean that you will rekindle
their love well maybe i will get back
together because now maybe
okay even though that sounded like a
hard pass
anderson isn't ruling out the idea of
baby number two
now do you think that you want wyatt to
have a sibling are you gonna have
another baby
i you know i don't know i i i there's
nothing in the works but
um i you know i don't know
i would yes i mean i would want to i
would love to
i think it would be great for him to to
have a yeah i'm not sure i can handle
like another but he's he's really such
an easy kid
wyatt's arrival came less than a year
after anderson's mom
gloria vanderbilt died at the age of 95.
when et spoke with a mother-son duo in
2016
gloria said she hoped her son would have
a child of his own one day
thanks for bringing this up this is not
as if this isn't an ongoing issue
doesn't every mother want their kid to
have yes i've heard this many times
believe me
for her you have to i know the clock is
ticking
[Music]
you